Speaker 1: We worried that this would happen and
it's happening. COVID anti-vaccine sentiment is
now bleeding over into other vaccines, and
parents are increasingly hesitant to get
their kids vaccinated against all sorts of
other things, including measles. And one of
those. And one of the problems with that
is we are now starting to see outbreaks
exactly as predicted. You might remember back in
November, we talked about this story. CNN reported
as measles outbreak sickens more than a dozen
children in Ohio. Local health officials seek
help from the CDC. A growing measles outbreak
in Columbus has sickened more than a dozen
unvaccinated children and hospitalized nine of
them. Look at that ratio, 75% hospitalization.
We often forget how serious measles is,
particularly in kids, because vaccination
is so effective. And this leads to some parents
saying, who ever heard of a kid getting measles?
It doesn't sound like it's likely and it certainly
doesn't sound serious. That's because of vaccines.
We have a report now from NBC4 about how vaccine
hesitancy that has sort of spilled over from
COVID vaccines into other vaccines is causing
exactly this problem. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 2: Hey, everybody. US childhood
vaccinations have dipped again this
year. A new report from the CDC suggests. What
started as a concern about the COVID 19 vaccine,
especially in younger people, is now carrying
over into other shots, too, including polio,
diphtheria and measles. It's likely one of the
reasons cluster outbreaks of diseases such as
measles are on the rise. CDC reports show last
year it was in the Twin Cities Minnesota area.
Currently, it's in and around Columbus, Ohio.
Speaker 3: In the Columbus outbreak,
there were over 85 cases and can be counting.
That was compared to last week's data. But over
30 of those kids were hospitalized and most
of those cases were in unvaccinated children.
Speaker 2: Yeah, Dr. Drew, his work is a
pediatrician who told me this new report
shows overall those receiving vaccines required
by most states is now at about 93%. It was at
95% just two years ago before the pandemic.
Speaker 1: Now that 93 and 95% number is actually
critically important. The herd immunity, measles
is so contagious that the herd immunity threshold
to prevent outbreaks is considered to be 95%.
That is dropped to 93% when it comes to children
entering kindergarten with with the required
immunizations, 93%. When you are below, you know,
people think, oh, this is some vague thing. It's
just numbers. No, it has real world consequences
when you go below that herd immunity threshold for
some diseases. You will start to see outbreaks.
And that is exactly what is going on. And this
was the fear that the COVID anti-vaxxers who first
entered Anti-vaxxer ism with the COVID vaccine
would bleed over into more general opposition to
child vaccinations because the general environment
starts to become one of vaccine hesitancy. And
if you get enough people in a community that
are skeptical or opposed to vaccines, it can
make others in the community more likely to say,
well, if these three families aren't doing it,
maybe I shouldn't do it either. If the health
care providers, if the public health officials
are well prepared to deal with the vaccine
hesitancy, they are going to be under-resourced
and not able to keep those vaccine rates up.
And I've spoken to a number of pediatricians,
I know friends of mine who say I get more people
than ever, even in liberal areas, people coming to
me and saying, you know, does my child really
need all these vaccines? Some of these things
don't really seem super serious or they don't seem
super common or likely that my child would get.
And the pediatricians have to explain,
well, that's because of the success and
effectiveness of many of these vaccines. This is a
separate conversation from the COVID vaccine. And
unfortunately, what we expected to see happen is
indeed happening as we see in these reports. What
will turn it around? I quite frankly, don't know.
It's pretty horrifying, to be totally honest.